ali samson luc ferrandez on va parler de
ça entre autres on va revenir sur le
publisac
est ce que c'est la fin parce que
transcontinental ne voudra pas faire
moins jadot j'entends mais d'abord
parlons des chiens dans le métro
une visite chez le vétérinaire chez des
amis ou simplement pour des balades vos
compagnons à quatre pattes ont aussi
besoin de se déplacer mais sans voiture
les options sont limitées qu'anglais
faire le transport en commun avec un
chien mais nous étions aux propos il
faut tout à trouver un autre moyen
les animaux de compagnie peuvent voyager
à bord des autobus et du métro de
montréal mais seulement s'ils sont dans
une cage ou un sac de transport
l'opposition officielle réclame des
changements se demander je pensais un
engouement une pétition lancée par la
spa a déjà récolté près de 17 mille
signatures à cela s'ajoute une notion
d'ensemble montréal qui sera déposé au
prochain conseil municipal leur demande
autoriser les chiens en laisse dans
l'ensemble du réseau de transport de la
stm ici six mois l'idée en herbe de 6
mois c'est justement pour trouver des
façons de faire si on veut le faire un
transport en commun j'ai de la chance
les vétérinaires il est à pied mais
c'est vrai que mâcher pas juste pour
aller se balader dans d'autres en europe
ça serait fantastique
ben oui c'est les animaux si t'as pas
une parole
forte houle
et l'idée n'est pas nouvelle loin de là
au pays toronto et calgary permettent
les animaux de compagnie dans les
transports en commun ailleurs londres
amsterdam copenhague et madrid pour
nomique civils ont aussi légiféré en ce
sens une ville qui se respecte doit
avoir des mesures c'est une mesure
extrêmement simple de mettre en place
l'association des médecins vétérinaires
du québec estime que plus de la moitié
des foyers ont au moins un chien ou un
chat la pandémie a poussé bien des
familles à adopter un animal on observe
une hausse d'environ 200 mille animaux
en deux ans ici qui me permettrait au
canada montréal
ça s'était calmé annie et l'udc sur le
front des chiens il ya quelques années
ou souvenirs épouvantable et paintball
way des bornes bon chez dans le métro me
semble que oui avec des règlements annie
est ce qu'un problème avec ça non moi je
pense que bien encadrée parce qu'il faut
se souvenir qu'il ya des gens qui ont
peur des animaux et des gens qui sont
allergiques donc si on veut permettre
moi je permettrai en tout cas je
trouverais intéressant qu'on puisse le
faire en dehors des heures de pointe
premièrement parce que les bus vont être
bondé in métro on réserve peut-être le
derrière de l'autobus et la même chose
le dernier waggon du métro pour le faire
donc les gens qui vont prendre le
dernier wagon vont savoir que des chiens
donc au moins en connaissance de cause
parce que oui a de plus en plus
d'animaux compte tenu de la coved les
gens se sont acheté des animaux de
compagnie évidemment pour se tenir
compagnie à l'intérieur et maintenant on
va prendre dollars dehors mais
effectivement il ya des gens qui ont
besoin de prendre le transport en commun
pour se déplacer et moi je pense que ça
pourrait être une bonne idée mais bien
entendre et donc pour être sûr que les
chiens mordent pas et emma mmo si j'irai
jusqu'à une muselière parce que des
chiens dans un autobus peuvent être
énervé peuvent les gens au top les
enfants vont vouloir aller jouer il faut
faire attention le pour ça se passe
mettons-nous vrai mal voté alpes et tout
ce qui va avec pour être sûr que tout le
monde est en sécurité moi je mets mon
chien dans un escalier roulant
oui je vais pas le tenir jusqu à l
contre les médias qui à me reprocher
beaucoup là
bas oui alors manitou tout à fait les
autres je trouve que c'est intéressant
les règlements animalier qui a été avec
la vie d'environ 2 à bac + met la table
pour ce genre de nouvelles possibilités
premièrement un chien dangereux celle
qui a déjà mordu mais condom on analyse
qui ne doit pas faire l'objet d'une
euthanasie il doit porter une muselière
deuxièmement a laissé seulement 85
troisièmement c'est un chien de plus de
vecchi 12 il doit avoir un
comme on appelle ce plus que ne l'est
le harnais et donc s'ils mesurent déjà
ces mesures-là ensuite les mesures qu'on
était au front pendant les parcs à
chiens dans les parcs à chiens on peut
pas amener une chienne en chaleur parce
que ça génère beaucoup d'agressivité
chez les chiens mal alors ces déchets
doivent être stérilisés
manière alors s'assurer de la
stérilisation
bien imprimer règlement sur les chiens
dangereux et après sa dette go et puis
aussi il faut
pas aussi facile dossier facile le plus
celui très bien de la propreté aussi
d'autres fois parlé oui mais vous avez
dit l'autre fois que vous trouviez que
les propriétaires de chiens maintenant
montréal était discipliné et ramassait
les petits cadeaux n'est plus en plus
totalement moi je ne m'attends pas à
voir un chien
uriner ou avoir des déjections canines
dans le métro la jeune belge a
ok
publisac la mairesse hier annoncé que
sera maintenant désormais les gens qui
en veulent qu'à recevront le problème
c'est que entre autres
l'entreprise qui fabrique qui produit
qui distribue les publisacs
transcontinental dit si on baisse de 800
à 1000 par semaine à 300 milles ça sera
plus rentable on écoute un représentant
depuis de transcontinental
est fondamentalement en désaccord avec
le opt-in qui signifierait la fin du
publisac c'est un modèle de la vague qui
ne fonctionne pas alors donc c'est
l'équivalent de bannir le publisac
bon pour transcontinental c'est
l'équivalent de bannir le publisac est
ce que c'est une négociation
comment voyez ce jeu commence avec voulu
moi j'ai trois je pense que le publisac
c'est la deuxième méthode la plus
polluante de distribuer de l'information
après le les bombardiers qui envoient
des tracas partir
d'hier d'envoyer des annonces de pizzas
à tout le monde en espérant qu'il ya un
sur vingt au sol sur 40 qui soient
susceptibles d'avoir besoin de la pizza
et de cet assassinat c'est extrêmement
polluant on n'est plus là je veux dire
ça c'est inadmissible
c'est inadmissible comme méthode de
distribution et de nous dire on va
perdre des emplois on est en plein
emploi ont vu récupérer des emplois
faire travailler ces gens là dans des
métiers où ils vont avoir une valeur
ajoutée pour la société pas une valeur
de destruction de la forêt d'une part et
de pollution de création de déchets
d'autre part donc vous êtes tant mieux
si transcontinental élimine même ce
procédé complètement avons
totalement et cc 2 temps que ça arrive
je veux dire aux antilles tout en re
sauver la planète oui mais pas ceux ci
oui même pas selon mes pensées leurs
gardes c'est un projet simple c'est un
projet simple c'est-à-dire 94 % des
citoyens ont internet ils s'en servent
peut-être pas pour accumuler de
l'information sur les rabais mais ils
ont internet où on est c'est un déchet
c'est 500 tonnes de déchets par semaine
et on
on se demande comment ça se fait que
c'est encore là après plusieurs motions
plusieurs études en question n'est pas
est venu à nice ceux qui en ont besoin
et ce qu'ils tiennent ou publisac ceux
qui veulent vous qui ont pas soin qui
ont internet mais qui rend con pas la
labilité d'y aller soi qui n'ont pas
internet du tout s coeur ils risquent
pas de tomber dans le dans la crac
c'est là dessus que je la voulais parler
patrice premièrement acpo des déchets
c'est des papiers qui sont recyclables
pour faut dire ça mais il faudrait que
la ville a de la misère avec son service
de recyclage faxer succès comme des
poubelles parce que mon parti sera pas
là dessus mais effectivement une
clientèle qui vont être pénalisés là
dedans moi j'ai un autre solution puis
je ne sais pas parce que lorsqu'il
suggérer c'est qu'on enlève le sac de
plastique picon médecins dans du papier
mais là on se rend compte que lorsque on
distribue les publisacs ans dans des
sacs de papier sur des escaliers pipe le
bain là ça devient un vrai paquet de
chips et sera pas beau mais on pourrait
à tout le moins mettre des distributeurs
des présentoirs le convoi dans certains
bâtiments un peu un peu partout dans les
lieux publics dans les métros dans les
stations des guichets automatiques des
endroits où les gens ils vont
naturellement et l'eau s'ils veulent en
prendre ils pourront choisir celui
qu'ils veulent donc être pas de
gaspillage la personne va le faire
volontairement parce qu'imaginez le
petit livre arles qui commence qui
rentre dans les rues de montréal et puis
qui va regarder est-ce que celui le
source au troisième étage qui monte
c'est un russe ennemis arrivant au total
puis finalement il ya le groupe qui dit
jean repos mais la spo mieux mais aussi
en un qui dit ker veux un et là imaginer
les gens qui font la livraison comment
ils vont faire combien de temps ça va
prendre ça reporte le bon sens ça sera
pas viable et si financièrement ce n'est
pas viable pour la compagnie on verra ce
qui se passe mais oubliez pas que
mirabel le fait et mirabel et en cour
supérieure actuellement on attend le
public transcontinents et chanteur ville
on devra avoir des résultats dans les
prochaines semaines et là ils vont
statuer parce que montréal fait
exactement la même chose donc on verra
rendu là peut-être qu on s'en reparlera
clé mais elle est vidé les présentoirs
moi je pense que c'est important et
intéressant présentoirs puis le goût dit
ça fait partie du passé comme les
bottins quand on est jeune on recevait
les bottes un jean blanc on reçoit pu
son
mari victor est un petit bon quand même
oui l'udc
domination de la cac
on a beaucoup parlé les partis
d'opposition ont essayé de justifier
leur mauvais score le pq arrive deuxième
c'est pas si loin derrière mais quand
même c'est un château fort paix qu'ils
vos réflexions sur ce compte est tout
près de montréal de longueuil le
bon d'avoir visé s'annonce très mal pour
la prochaine élection à la fois pour le
parti québécois et pour le parti libéral
mais on s'y attendait un peu on s'y
attendait un peu la cac est en état de
grâce est aidé par l'économie est
soutenue par la population
les années de covile ont permis à
monsieur le goût d'apparaître comme un
bon père de famille bon gestionnaire
entre guillemets évidemment il ya des
défauts mais très difficile de le battre
en ce moment maintenant que va-t-il
arriver à l'ensemble des partis québec
thunder a mal fait ou six à sept points
de pourcentage de réduction on parle du
pq que perdu alors que pq est resté à 30
pour ça mais c'est dans un dans un
château fort alors on s'attendait à ce
qu'il y a pas un parti il n'y a pas un
parti qui va pouvoir et ça inclut les
conservateurs qui sont à monter mais qui
sont quand même plafonné n'y a pas un
parti qui va pouvoir menacer la caq aux
prochaines élections les quatre
prochaines années sont rodés année du
gouvernement de cas est largement et
vous le dites les libéraux qui sont
arrivés cinquième quand même avec 6,9
pour cent des voix c'est il avait eu 14
15 la dernière fois que c'est une
dégringolade pour les libéraux sont pas
allés voter tout simplement annie
l'atuge jean ferrat plus de pause sur ce
que le codi historiquement lorsque des
partielles dans des comptes est donc un
nul trois là depuis l'arrivée de
monsieur legault les persiennes
absolument donne tout le temps la chance
aux gens de l'opposition de dany c'est
rare que les partis au pouvoir gang
l'hyper ciel c'est rare mais de 80 % et
+ le sait tout le temps les partis
d'opposition dans ce cas aussi la cac a
gagné les trois dernières partielles
c'est quand même un signe dans lequel
les gens sont quand même très satisfait
du travail qui se passe on l'a vu le
avec avec tout ce qui s'est passé la
dernière semaine et on rentre tout les
scandales les mines tout ce qui à
l'époque tout le monde a lancé de la bvk
peu partout puis finalement ils ont
réussi quand même à passer haut la main
et la plus grosse défaite effectivement
c'est le parti libéral j'ai des amis au
parti vert comme j'en ai dans tous les
partis mais qui se pensaient
probablement mais nice à la prochaine
élection et là je pense qu en a beaucoup
qui hier soir ont prime de choix
leurs idéaux d'aller plus loin ils vont
encore rester dans l'opposition au moins
combler quelque chose qui arrive qu'on
voit pas le processus pour l'existant
les dents et éclaircies pour le temps
c'est un chemin royal pour monsieur
legault dir weh grand point positif pour
la nouvelle députée qui vient d'un
milieu médical donc le milieu qui va
parler à monsieur à monsieur dubé
évidemment sur la refondation du système
pré hospitaliers j'écoutais précédemment
a tantôt où elle parlait justement d
horreur le temps spirit tracks en
ukraine oui moi je très concret je dois
vous dois vous dire merci parce que
merci beaucoup à vous deux à la
prochaine merci l'impression